five years ago I stood on the Ted stage
I spoke about my work but one year later
I had a terrible accident as I left a
pub one dark night with friends in
Scotland as we followed the paths of a
forest I suddenly felt a massive thud
then a second third and I fell to the
ground and had no idea what had hit me I
later found out that when the gate was
opened in a garden a wild stag stampeded
along the path and ran straight into me
and its antler penetrated my trachea and
my esophagus and stopped at my spinal
cord and fractured my neck my best
friend found me lying on the floor
gurgling for help through a hole in my
neck and we locked eyes on although I
couldn't speak she could understand what
I was thinking and she told me just
breathe and so whilst focusing on my
breath I had a strong sense of calmness
but I was certain that I was going to
die and somehow I was content with this
because I've always tried to do my best
in life whenever I can so I just
continued to enjoy each breath as one
more moment one breath in and one breath
out and an ambulance came I was still
fully conscious and I analyzed
everything on the journey because I'm a
scientist the sound of the tires on the
road the frequency of the street lights
and eventually the city street lights
and I thought maybe I will survive and
then I passed out I was stabilized at a
local hospital and then airlifted to
Glasgow where they reconstructed my
throat and put me in a coma and and
while I was in the coma I had many
alternate realities it was like a crazy
mix of West world and Black Mirror but
that's the whole other story and my
local TV station reported live from
outside the hospital of a Cambridge
scientist who was in a coma and they
didn't know if she would live or die or
walk or talk and a week later I woke up
from that coma
and that was the first gift and then I
had the gift to think the gift to move
the gift to breathe and the gift to eat
and to drink and that took three and a
half months but there was one thing that
I never got back though and that was my
privacy the tabloid press made the story
about gender look I'm transgender it's
not that big a deal like my my hair
color or my shoe size is way more
interesting and when I last spoke here
with them when I last spoke here let's
head I didn't talk about it because it's
boring and one Scottish newspaper ran
with the headline sex swap scientist
gored by stag and five others did
similar things and for a minute I was
angry but then I found my calm place and
what vans in my head was they've crossed
the wrong woman
and they're not going to know what's hit
them I guess I'm a kindness ninja I
don't really know what a ninja does but
to me they slipped at the shadows crawl
through the sewers skip across the
rooftops before you know it they're
behind you they don't turn it with an
army or complain and they're laser
focused on a plan so when I lay in my
hospital bed I thought of my plan to
help reduce the chances of them doing
this to somebody else by using the
system as is and paying the price of
sacrificing my privacy what they told 1
million people
I will tell 10 million people because
when you're angry people defend
themselves and so I didn't attack them
and they were defenseless and I wrote
kind and calm letters to these
newspapers and the Sun newspaper the
kind of Fox News of the UK thanked me
for my reasoned approach and I asked for
no apology no retraction no money just
an acknowledgment that they broke their
own rules and what they did was just
wrong and on this journey I started to
learn who they are and they began to
learn Who I am and we actually became
friends and I've even had a few glasses
of wine with Philippa from the Sun since
then and after three months they all
agreed and the statements were published
on a Friday and that was the end of that
or so they thought on the Saturday I
went on the evening news
and with the headline six national
newspapers admit they are wrong and the
anchor said to me but don't you think
it's our job as journalists to
sensationalize a story and I said I was
lay on a forest floor gored by a stag is
that not sensational enough and I was
now right in the headlines and my
favorite one was the stag trampled on my
throat and the press trampled on my
privacy and it was the most read piece
of BBC News Online that day and I was
kind of having fun and by the end of my
week of media I started to use my
newfound voice and platform to spread a
message of love and kindness and when I
had the minute of anger and hatred
towards those fests and journalists I
had to identify my inner bigotry towards
them and I had to meet and speak with
these people without judgment and I had
to let myself understand them and in
return they began to understand me well
six months later they asked me to join
the committee that regulates the press
and a few times a year I sipped tea and
dipped biscuits with the likes of Daily
Mail editor Paul Dacre who says to me so
Kate have your last few months been and
I respect them and I am now one of three
members of the public who has a seat at
the table not because I'm different but
because my voice counts just like
anybody else
and the irony is every now and again I'm
asked to visit those printing presses of
this declining industry because some
people think that the technology I spoke
about here last time it said my
interactive print might actually help
save them so beware if you're in a
bigger and make friends from your
enemies thank you
[Applause]